is the ultimate Bitcoin cheat sheet that
you need to know going into the end of
this year and 2025. As you know, we're
already in the banana zone. So, we'll be
talking about this in a lot of detail in
the next few charts. So, subscribe to
the channel for more videos like this in
the future. Like this video if you enjoy
content like this going forward. And
let's dive right into it. So, we're very
familiar with the boring zone and the
banana zone. The boring zone tends to
occur for quite a few months after the
halving event, but that tends to precede
parabolic price action towards the
upside. And we've seen this across
cycles from 2012 to 2016.
And of course, 2020 to then
really transitioning into this cycle,
2024, and now we are in the banana zone
very firmly.
And as you can see, we've been talking
about this reaccumulation phase for a
long time. And one of the things to
really take note of is that this
reaccumulation phase in 2020,
post-halving reaccumulation, that lasted
163 days. In this cycle, we saw that
reaccumulation phase elongate and extend
by an additional 45 days or so. And
that's really important to take note
because if we're considering a parabolic
phase from 2020, which lasted 385 days,
can we really consider a copy-paste
scenario based on the fact that
potentially this reaccumulation phase
has
potentially eaten into our parabolic
phase. So, if we talk about 160 days,
and then we have those extra 145 days
that otherwise could have been in the
parabolic upside phase.
Does it mean that this reaccumulation
phase
eaten to this parabolic upside phase? or
are we going to actually see the
parabolic phase extend a little bit? And
from my perspective, I think this would
mean that the parabolic phase is a
little bit shorter.
And it's better to talk about it in
worst-case scenarios because that would
just mean that this parabolic phase in
the cycle could be shorter by 45 days.
And And let's just entertain that for a
second because when we're talking about
this banana zone,
things really go parabolic. We've seen
that so many times in the past, and
let's just talk about some of these
zones because we'd see uninterrupted
upside, small dips on the upside, and
very few corrections in the middle.
So, these corrections tend to occur.
Those tend to be fantastic buy-side
opportunities, especially if you
consider the first major corrections.
So, we had a first major correction here
in the 2016 cycle, and then a second
major correction, but the third major
correction, that was already the end of
the bull market. So, going back to 2020
here, here we have a dip. Here we have
that first major correction, maybe a
second major correction, and then we
don't get a third major correction. So,
we do see the bear market develop after
that bull market peak. So, going back to
2012, for example,
we see very few moments of respite and
pulling back for Bitcoin's price action.
So, once we do crash
after a 300-day parabolic upside period,
that tends to be the end of the bull
market. So,
we're probably going to be getting
a dip at some point.
Right?
We're probably going to get
a price discovery
correction at some point, as we've seen
in the past.
We might get a second one
in the future as well, as we've seen in
the past.
But in the meantime, we're going to see
price discovery uptrend number one.
And so this is really that sort of
ultimate
cheat sheet that's going to really guide
you over these next few months and 2025.
We have that first parabolic uptrend and
that dipping there. Here, first
parabolic uptrend before that dipping.
So that's the first parabolic uptrend.
Then we get that dip,
which across cycles tends to happen. We
then see the second parabolic upside, as
you can see here, cross cycle, and then,
of course, that major correction,
which essentially you can just do this,
right? Because
we see a correction here, a correction
here, we'll see a correction here as
well at some point. And then maybe one
one final correction near the top. And
that just gives us an idea in terms of
the road map of what to expect going
forward. But if we're talking about
these reaccumulation phases, this was
160 days after having this was slightly
longer at 205 days after the having.
2016 gives us a bit more clarity on the
fact that this was 150 days after the
having, 154 days after having that this
reaccumulation phase took place. But
then you can actually see that the
parabolic phase of the cycle actually
lasts 350 days. So if we're comparing
2020 in that regard,
the 2016 phase was slightly shorter. So
we have 385 days parabolic upside in
2020, 357 days parabolic upside in 2016.
So are we seeing some sort of extension
in the parabolic phase from 2016 to
2020?
And so it's a little bit There are quite
a a
variables because we're seeing an
extension in the reaccumulation phase by
45 days. And if we're comparing
the 385
days of 2020 and 360 days of 2016, then
there's an extension in the parabolic
phase of the cycle by some
30 days almost. So, if we've extended by
45 days in the reaccumulation phase, and
we tend to see some extension by
30 days or so in the parabolic phase of
the cycle across time,
then does this extension then cancel out
with that potential extension
in the parabolic phase of the cycle that
we tend to see? Overall, I talk about
this in a lot of detail in the Rekt
Capital newsletter, in my most recent
newsletter, so feel free to check out
the link in the description down below,
and feel free to read and really find
out what I talk about and how I come up
with the idea that maybe we do see a
slightly uh earlier peak in the bull
market as a result of the acceleration
that's still remaining in the cycle.
Remember, we broke out 2 weeks before
schedule in terms of the 214 days after
having where we tend to see new all-time
highs. We broke out 205 days after
having, so a bit of a 2-week
acceleration there.
But that's pretty phenomenal, because
when we peaked in the first old or new
all-time high at the time, this was an
acceleration of 260 days, 260 days, and
we narrowed that down to just 14 days,
which is impressive, dramatic, but
nonetheless, there is a lingering rate
of acceleration in this cycle that we
simply cannot ignore. And if we just
take away 14 days from this potential
period here, we factor in the fact that
we have 45 days right over here,
and maybe we do see an extension in
terms of parabolic upside across phases
and across cycles,
then really, what do we come down to? We
come down to a conservative estimate of
approximately 300 days. And that just
gives you a bit of an average. It
factors in the worst-case scenario that
we top out a little bit sooner.
Factors in the acceleration of the
cycle. It factors in the extended
reaccumulation phase in this cycle. It
factors in quite a few variables that
most people aren't going to factor in
because it's not really
engagement-worthy. Whereas here, we're
actually trying to come up with a
realistic roadmap and plan to financial
freedom. And that's what we always do
here on the channel, on my Twitter, on
my X. We always do that in the right
captain newsletter. So, if you haven't
signed up to the newsletter, feel free
to click in the link in the description
down below.
But I think it's really important to
also talk about diminishing returns and
the fact that we are exiting this
reaccumulation phase of the cycle. We
always see reaccumulation around old
all-time highs. We tend to see these
ranges be either very short,
very zigzaggy, and very volatile,
very short again, or extremely
overextended in terms of time. 205 days.
Let's repeat that.
But then inevitably we transition out of
that phase. And you can see here that of
course we tend to see phenomenal upside
to the next bull market peak, the final
new all-time high that we get
before the bear market. But of course we
have to understand that there is
diminishing returns involved in each of
these cycles. And that doesn't mean that
we're going to struggle in this cycle,
but we have to be cognizant of some of
the changes that inevitably occur in the
maturing
asset class that Bitcoin is. And what's
interesting is that this chart simply
can't keep up with the price action
because Bitcoin right now is at 91 and
1/2 K and that's a little bit too quick
for this price chart to keep up. And the
BNC, the Bitcoin liquid index, it's
great to just showcase history dating
back to even 2011, but does struggle to
keep up with the price action in real
time. But nonetheless,
I do digress. If we talk about
diminishing returns and we think about
maybe having having some of that
diminishing some of those returns, then
that still gets us into 150, 130, 120.
So, there is still upside left to enjoy
for Bitcoin's price action. And if we
talk about some of these phases in terms
of length, then
this is something we get to enjoy in
terms of a 300-day window for the
parabolic phase of the cycle. And the
parabolic phase of the cycle isn't by
any means smooth sailing. You can see
that we tend to see corrections on the
way up.
Those are your moments for dollar cost
averaging into the market, but it's
important to do so more with conviction
in the very early stages of those price
discovery waves.
And if we talk about diminishing returns
across cycles, then we need to talk
about diminishing returns across price
discovery uptrends. So, this is that
price discovery uptrend in the very
first 8 weeks of price discovery. And
over here, we had this for 4 weeks. So,
this was the first price discovery
uptrend. And notice how that also
diminishes across time
in 2017. And then you'll notice here as
well in 2021,
where we also diminish before we finally
pull back, but not that much, which is
quite interesting. That diminishing rate
of return isn't that interesting and I'm
or at least too big, what I'm trying to
say.
And so,
if we do something like this, then of
course we need to factor that
diminishing rate of return.
But, does give us an idea that
well, maybe we're halfway through this
price discovery wave, potentially,
with a little bit more. So, maybe 40%
more in this price discovery wave, this
very first one, before we've then see
that first major price discovery
correction in the future.
And of course,
it's bound to happen.
And
really, don't ignore it because
they can be That's a high-probability
opportunity
that really lays ahead. And 2013 showed
us that this can be quite a significant
opportunity. But, this is 25%
for example.
Here, that's also some 30-25% and this
lasts 2 to 3 weeks.
Here, it lasted a little bit longer than
that.
But, it's enough to convince people that
the bull market is over and that the
bear market is beginning. And so, people
are going to think that we're already
here and going to experience a year-long
bear market, whereas we still have quite
a bit of upside left to enjoy. So,
price discovery wave one is right
underway.
It's It's already in play. It's 2 weeks
in. We saw a 4-week price discovery wave
here. We saw an 8-week price discovery
wave here. We saw a 6-weeks price
discovery wave right over here. And then
we saw a several-week price discovery
correction afterwards.
Multi-week price discovery correction
afterwards.
And then multi-week price discovery
correction afterwards as well. But, then
what follows is that next price
discovery wave in 2020. Here again,
but just notice how we then transition
into another price discovery correction.
And even in 2013, you can see that once
we finally transition out from In fact,
if you think about this as the price
discovery waves wave two, then you see
this is a 25% reaccumulation phase and
pullback opportunity. So, that's price
discovery correction number two in 2013.
And then we embark on that last price
discovery wave towards the upside in
2013. And here is the same for 2017.
Maybe a small dip in the meantime. And
of course, this is that final price
discovery wave in 2021.
So, essentially, the the real takeaways
here are price discovery wave uptrend
number one is in progress still. It's
only week two, so still a few weeks
left. We have four to eight weeks
generally in this price discovery wave.
Then we could suffer a major price
discovery correction of approximately
25%, 30%, maybe 20%. That's going to
last two to three weeks. Then we're
going to see that second price discovery
uptrend wave before we
have that price discovery correction,
that second one, which could also be
once again a 30% pullback. And then the
final price discovery wave into new
all-time highs. And that's probably
That's probably going to be it. That's
going to be the new all-time highs, the
final all-time highs. And that's going
to be it for that sort of price
appreciation. So, I talk about
whether we're going to have a shorter
parabolic upside phase in Direct Capital
newsletter.
Check it out. Find out more. Click in
the link in the description down below
to read more about it. I talk about the
price discovery waves in a lot of detail
in Direct Capital newsletter. Check out
the link in the description. Find out
more. Read more about it. There are so
many opportunities still left in the
market when it comes to Bitcoin's price
action with these potential price
discovery corrections still ahead in the
future.
But just note that altcoins haven't yet
even begun their macro uptrends. They're
only just beginning their uptrends. So
still so much more to enjoy when it
comes to altcoins and still so much left
ahead for Bitcoin. But not too much left
in this video. That's about it for
today's video. Thanks so much. Subscribe
to the channel for more videos like this
in the future. Like this video if you
enjoy content like this going forward.
I'm Marx Capital and I'll speak to you
in the next one. Speak to you soon.